what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm your host
Warren Thompson we have a ton of news to
talk about today concerning the new and
upcoming MCU reboot of the Fantastic
Four it looks like we know who our main
villain is going to be as well as one or
two maybe even more sub villains of the
movie we know that Marvel Studios likes
to do that sometimes with some of their
films and projects and we do have an
update on who some of the cast members
could be playing the role of the villain
we have a huge plot detail about the
movie that we have to go over today and
yes there has been some casting news it
seems like one character is definitely
locked in According to some reports and
it looks like the entire cast might have
actually been found it looks like Marvel
Studios has officially offered the roles
to certain actors and it's up to them
now to Simply accept and according to
some recent reports that will go over
some of these actors have accepted the
roles but of course we'll have to wait
and see on that but we'll break down the
new plot details and the villains
villains of this film in this video and
also big congratulations to YouTube user
coffee
shakes86 for being the winner of our
July giveaway you've been messaged and
congratulations also we're doing another
giveaway we do one every month so if you
want a chance to win an Xbox series X A
PS5 some Marvel Legends items or some DC
items all you got to do is subscribe and
leave a comment Down Below in the videos
for a chance to win we pick one winner
at the end of each month and the winner
picks one item so let's talk about this
major plot Point first before we dive
into the villain because I think that
this is super interesting this was
rumored or at least the rumor began
about three years ago maybe even four
since Kevin feige announced the
Fantastic Four film was going to be in
development soon at San Diego Comic-Con
four years ago back in 2019 seems like
forever ago now but according to Grace
Randolph the Fantastic Four film is
going to be set in the 1960s and they
will be sent out of time like Captain
America and I actually think that this
is a super cool idea because they are
what is referred to as Marvel's first
family they were literally Marvel's
first superhero team of the Silver age
and they're actually a family Reed
Richards and Sue storm are married they
have kids in the comics Johnny Storm is
the brother of Sue storm of course and
Ben Grimm is the best friend of Reed
Richards and the surrogate brother and
Uncle so they're literally a family and
putting this film back in the 1960s
making the events of the movie take
place not too long after the events of
Captain America and Captain Marvel could
tie them into the MCU in a really really
cool way but not to mention Mr Fantastic
Reed Richards could have ties to Tony
Stark's father Howard Stark and or Hank
him so there are a lot of really cool
connections that we could have here and
a lot of cool cameos that could possibly
take place in the Fantastic Four film if
it is indeed set back in the 1960s now
of course I know the question that many
people are probably going to ask is well
well how exactly do they get time
displaced and end up in our time and the
first thing that comes to our minds is
the Quantum realm the Fantastic Four
have a huge history with the Negative
Zone and although the MCU doesn't
necessarily have a negative Zone per se
we do have the quantum realm a place
that exists outside of space and time
and the Fantastic Four could get stuck
inside of the quantum realm get pulled
in somehow perhaps maybe by Kang Maybe
by Modoc just like Ant-Man and everybody
was pulled in and since Kang is now not
there anymore the Fantastic Four could
stumble upon Kang's technology and read
Richard the smartest man alive could use
that technology to get his family out of
the quantum realm but could end up in
present time they could pull them to
2025 and that's where the connections
could come in since Reed Richards is the
smartest man alive if he went forward
into the future he would realize that
pretty quickly from there he would
probably seek people that he knew back
in 1960 he would probably first try to
find the Baxter building which could
possibly already exist of the Fantastic
Four were existing in 1960 and it might
not be there anymore or it could be
occupied by somebody else then he'll
start to seek out people he knows
probably Howard Stark and what she's no
longer alive but his son Tony Stark is
known by everybody on Earth because he
saved everybody so he could possibly go
to find Tony Howard and run into pepper
pots or like I mentioned another one
would be Hank Pym and Janet Van Dyne or
perhaps Hank Pym and Janet Van Dyne are
the ones who pull them out of the
quantum realm there are really cool
possibilities of how they could go in
the quantum realm and get pulled out and
I think this is our best bet of how they
become time displaced now as far as the
villain is concerned according to a
recent report by Insider Jeff Snyder the
villain is indeed going to be Galactus
who we have all hoped for a true
non-cloud Galactus and here's where we
get some casting info from Jeff Snyder
concerning Galactus first since we're
talking about Galactus he states that
they want the actor that is going to
play Galactus to be Latino this lines up
with the rumor report that we've heard
that Antonio Banderas is wanted by
Marvel Studios to play Galactus and
Antonio Banderas does consider himself
Latino he says when I've gone to the US
I've considered myself Latino just want
to specify that because he is actually
from Spain so that further backs up the
report that Antonio Banderas could play
Galactus and we also have a report about
who could possibly be playing the Silver
Surfer according to Jeff Schneider Ebon
Moss Bachrach who was being rumored to
have been offered the role of the thing
could possibly be playing the Silver
Surfer now this is not confirmed and I
think it's kind of an educated guess by
Jeff Snyder because he says he's not
playing the thing but possibly the
Silver Surfer basically what this means
here is Ebon Moss bhaktaraj has been
offered some role by Marvel Studios and
the Insiders simply don't know which
role that is that's why he says it could
possibly be the role of the silver
server and if it is let me know what you
think about that casting and of course
Galactus as well now what's really
interesting about Galactus being the
main villain of this is he's a cosmic
entity so even if the Fantastic Four
somehow managed to defeat him or hold
him back he's gonna come back eventually
and this actually could set up Galactus
in a really cool way it could give him a
reason to come back to earth possibly
for Revenge but it could establish that
connection between Galactus and Earth
and the Fantastic Four they could fight
him off in the early 1960s and this
could set him up to return once again in
the future when they are now time
displaced in 2025. so a lot of really
cool possibilities here now according to
Jeff Snyder he has said on the hot mic
podcast that Vanessa Kirby is cast as
Sue storm she has been cast that role is
hers Marvel Studios offered it to her
and she accepted it so according to that
report that's our Sue storm I am
personally really happy with this
decision but let me know what you think
about it in the comments down below now
he also says that Johnny Storm is is
going to be played by Joseph Quinn now
we've talked about this before most
people know him from stranger things and
I think a lot of people are okay with
this casting I think a lot of people
like this casting and of course we want
to hear from you let us know what you
think about it down below now Grace
Randolph has come out and stated three
people that Marvel Studios wants to play
Mr Fantastic and according to her Adam
Driver is still a possibility she says
that Matt Smith Dev Patel and Adam
Driver are the top three that Marvel
Studios wants and in referring to Adam
Driver she states the MCU won't give up
meaning based on the reports that we've
heard before Marvel Studios did offer
the role to Adam Driver in which he
declined it because he couldn't really
connect with the character however it
seems like she has heard that Marvel
Studios really wants him to play Mr
Fantastic so they're not gonna stop
asking him or not going to stop
negotiating with him or trying to
convince him that the character is right
for him but Matt Smith is another name
that has been going around recently even
Daniel rpk stay stated that Marvel
Studios did offer him the role of Mr
Fantastic now most people know him from
Doctor Who House of the dragon and
morbius he's even been in the Star Wars
franchise so he is tight with Disney
which is Marvel Studios of course I
personally think that he is an
incredibly talented actor and probably
looks more like Reed Richards than Adam
Driver does but and no offense to him
I'm not sure he would be the perfect fit
for this role but of course let us know
what you think about it down below now
the other is Dev Patel and he's been
rumored for a pretty long time and I
actually do think he could pull off
quite a good Reed Richards look and he
is a very talented actor so I would be
okay with this now as far as the thing
is concerned Jeff Snyder says that he
has been cast but does not know who he
actually is but that means most of the
characters really everybody but Mr
Fantastic Reed Richards has been cast so
as soon as Reed Richards gets locked
down hopefully Marvel Studios will
officially announce the cast to us and
hopefully that is not far from happening
because everybody is really eager to
hear who the true cast of The Fantastic
Four is going to be but the fact that
the film could take place in the 1960s
and Galactus could be the main villain
with the Silver Surfer also appearing in
the movie is really really exciting and
could mean a lot of really cool things
could happen in the future of the MCU
especially with all of the connections
the Fantastic Four could have so lots of
exciting things happening with the
Fantastic Four and the Marvel Cinematic
Universe let me know your thoughts about
all of these casting reports down below
you love them do you hate them are they
just kind of meh let us know your
thoughts also don't forget to like the
video and of course if you subscribe and
leave a comment you're automatically
entered in our giveaway you can check
out our website you can check out our
Discord server and patreon and of course
you can follow us on Instagram and
Twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching wolf wolf
foreign